hello everyone welcome to the very first
screencast of the very first unit of our
course we're going to be talking about
distributed word representations or
vector representations of words
and for this screencast i'm just going
to cover some high-level goals we have
for this unit
as well as discuss the guiding
hypotheses not only for this unit but
also hypotheses that will be with us
throughout the quarter
what i've depicted on the slide here is
our starting point both conceptually and
computationally this is a small fragment
of a very large word by word
co-occurrence matrix so along the rows
here you have a large vocabulary of
words the first few are emoticons at
least word like objects
exactly that same vocabulary is repeated
across the columns
and the cell values here give the number
of times that each row word appeared
with each column word in a very large
text corpus
i think the big idea that you want to
start getting used to is that there
could be meaning latent in such
co-occurrence patterns
it's not obvious to mere mortals that we
could extract anything about meaning
from such an abstract space but we're
going to see time and time again this is
actually a very powerful basis for
developing meaning representations
to start building intuition let's do a
small thought experiment so imagine that
i give you a small lexicon of words each
one of them labeled as either negative
or positive in the sense of sentiment
analysis
now that might be a useful resource but
i've called this a hopeless learning
scenario because if i give you four new
anonymous words to make predictions on
this resource over here is not useful at
all for making predictions in fact you
have essentially no information to go on
about what these anonymous words should
be labeled
contrast that with a situation in which
i give you that label lexicon but in
addition
i give you the number of times that each
lexicon word co-occurs in some large
text corpus with the two words excellent
and terrible
i think with that information with those
columns from the word by word matrix you
can see that you have a lot of
predictive power in fact a really simple
classifier or even decision rule will be
able to do really well at predicting
these labels if a word co occurs more
often with terrible than excellent call
it negative
if a word co occurs with excellent more
often than terrible call it positive
that's a good predictive model and now
if i give you four new anonymous words
and in in addition you're allowed to
collect some co-occurrence information
about them with respect to excellent and
terrible then your same rule will be
able to make really good predictions
about these new anonymous words
that's the sense in which we've moved to
a very promising learning scenario and
it's just a glimpse of how we could
extract latent information about meaning
from these co-occurrence patterns and
now just play it forward and think the
vector space models that we'll be
building will have not just two
dimensions but hundreds or even
thousands of dimensions and there's no
telling how much information we'll find
latent in such a high dimensional space
so that brings me to these high-level
goals here first we want to begin
thinking about how these vectors could
encode meanings of linguistic units get
more used to that idea that i just
introduced you to
these are foundational concepts that
we'll be discussing not only for our
unit on vector space models which are
also called embeddings in modern
parlance but in fact these are
foundational concepts for all of the
more sophisticated deep learning models
that we'll be discussing later on in the
quarter
and of course i'm really hoping that
this this material is valuable to you
throughout the assignments that you do
and also valuable for the original
project work that you do in the second
half of the course
some guiding hypotheses let's start with
the literature i would be remiss in a
lecture like this if i didn't quote j.r
firth you shall know a word by the
company it keeps this is a glimpse at
the kind of nominalist position that
first took about how to do linguistic
analysis he's really saying that we
should trust distributional information
uh his
zelic harris a linguist working at
around the same time has an even purer
statement of this hypothesis harris said
distributional statements can cover all
of the material of a language without
requiring support from other types of
information
daily cares really only trusted usage
information i think we don't need to be
so extreme in our position but we can
certainly align with harris in thinking
that there could be a lot about language
latent in these distributional
statements that is in co-occurrence
patterns
we might as well quote wittgenstein the
meaning of a word is its use in the
language i think that's a nice
connection that wittgenstein might have
in mind might be a point of alignment
for him with firth and harris i'm not
sure
but finally here's a kind of direct
operationalization
of our high-level hypothesis this is
from one of the recommended readings by
attorney and pentel and they say if
units of text have similar vectors in a
text frequency matrix like the
co-occurrence matrix i showed you before
then they tend to have similar meanings
if we buy that hypothesis then we're
kind of licensed to build these
co-occurrence matrices and then make
inferences about at least similarity of
meaning on the basis of those objects
we've constructed
to finish here under the heading of
great power a great many design choices
i think one of the difficult things
about working in this space is that
there are a lot of moving pieces the
first choice you'll have to make is your
matrix design i've talked about the word
by word matrix but of course word by
document word by search proximity
adjective by modified noun these are all
different ways that you could construct
your rows and your columns in one of
these matrices and that's going to be
really fundamental you'll capture very
different distributional facts depending
on what kind of matrix design you choose
and in a way that's not even the first
choice that you need to make because in
constructing this matrix you'll make a
lot of choices about how to tokenize
whether to annotate what to do whether
do part of speech tagging for further
distinctions parsing feature selection
and so forth and so on you also have to
decide how you're going to group your
texts is your notion of co-occurrence
going to be based on the sentence or the
document or maybe documents clustered by
date or author or discourse context all
of those things will give you very
different notions of what it means to
co-occur and that will feed into your
matrix design
having made all of those difficult
choices you now you're probably going to
want to take your count matrix and as
we'll say re-weight it that is adjust
the values by stretching and bending the
space in order to find more latent
information about meaning we're going to
talk about a lot of methods for doing
that and then you might furthermore want
to do some kind of dimensionality
reduction which is a step you could take
to capture even more higher order
notions of co-occurrence beyond the
simple co-occurrences that you see
evident in the original matrix that's a
powerful step there are a lot of choices
you could make there
and then finally what's your notion of
similarity going to be for us we'll
operationalize that as a vector
comparison method like euclidean
distance cosine distance jacquard
distance and so forth
depending on previous choices that
you've made the choice of vector
comparison method might have a real
impact on what you regard as similar and
different in your vector space
so this is a kind of dizzying array of
choices that you might have to make
there is a glimmer of hope though so
models like glove and word vec purport
to offer packaged solutions at least to
the design weighting and reduction steps
here
so they'll tell you for instance if you
use glove that it needs to be word by
word and then glove will simultaneously
perform these two steps and furthermore
for these methods since they tend to
deliver vectors that are pretty well
scaled in terms of their individual
values the choice of vector comparison
might not matter so much so models like
glove and workvec are a real step
forward in terms of taming this space
here
and we can add further that more recent
contextual embedding models dictate even
more of the design choices possibly all
the way back to how you tokenize and so
they could be um thought of as even more
unified solutions to the great many
design choices that you have here so
that's kind of conceptually a real
breakthrough i will say though that
baseline models constructed from the
simple things that i have in these
tables here are often competitive with
more these more advanced models but of
course which combination is something
that you'll probably have to discuss
to have to discover empirically